okay I'm gonna start with you miss
because obviously it's Grammys weekend
we're all about music I know we're here
professional artists but you have a new
single out destiny just tell me about
the vibe of that destiny is a mix of R&B
gospel and a little blues and it's just
a song I wrote about a time in my life
that I thought maybe my dreams are not
going to come true because of choices
that I made as a young woman and I wrote
the song really about ten years ago but
pulled it out because the rebirth of my
music dream happens after having all the
children after you know rerouting my
life and so it's all about how destiny
is found kind of in ways you didn't
think you might find it now yeah isn't
it crazy how we think life is gonna go
one way and then we get thrown a lot of
let you know thrown in these loops and
situations and then we still come back
to our purpose it sounds like that's
what it's about it really is and you
know I always say that you don't know
the road that you're taking but God does
and you and you you might think that
you've turned the wrong way but you get
through that rabbit hole and go oh my
god this was what I always dreamed of
and my husband is a dream come true as
are my kids but music was also a dream
and I had to live it and I'm so thankful
that I'm able to I mean just talk about
how proud you are of this woman that
she's stepping on her dreams she's she's
already fulfilled some family dreams so
she's doing this for herself talk about
that you know she is doing it for
herself and this is also she is the best
example I ever have of someone who's
courageous who does not stop because
that's the thing whatever you dreamed
about doing when you were a little kid
you should still be doing somewhere
along the line you got talked out of it
and she didn't and that's the thing this
is what I love about her she's an
example when you're my inspiration
though honey you're my inspiration
because you talk about a person who
doesn't quit
I learned perseverance watching my
husband
bang his head up in the NFL bang his
head up in Hollywood and refused to stop
till he got where he was trying to be
and you are my inspiration relationship
goals before Valentine's Day me were
very really lucky right now I don't want
to talk about a really important
conversation that happened I mean you're
somebody that is just unapologetically
you you're gonna speak out for what you
believe in and you were getting a lot of
backlash for Liam Neeson I mean I feel
like it was a really important
conversation that had to be had can you
just talk about that in you know a lot
of people thought I was defending him
and I wasn't I was not defending him I
was just saying that basically he was
looking back at his life and the fork in
the road was that hey he could have been
a basic racist supremist kind of guy and
that was my that was my point it was
more of a observation it was going on
and people took it mistook it as I was
giving him a pass and I was like okay
I'm a black man I've been hunted how in
the world did you even construe that as
a pass and I thought yeah it's so
important to understand that evil has
many forms you put whatever word you
want in front of the ism it's just evil
it's human evil and we're capable of
being evil to each other and we're
capable of being good and I do want to
say this I don't want to say this is
that everybody has a fork in the road
I'm to tell you there have been many
many times I came very very close to not
being here
okay I'm from Flint Michigan you know
what I mean I could be in jail I could
be dead and let me tell you I took the
other Road that is me yes yes but that's
the point I was making now again does it
excuse him not at all but the fact is is
that he didn't that's the point the
point I was making is he didn't and you
know what thank God he didn't but there
are a lot of people who did right and we
would all be murderers and we'd all be
all kinds of things if we were held
guilty by our thoughts yeah first of all
I know nothing I even brought up the
fact that you know Trayvon Martin was
killed by somebody who did that's my
point
let's talk about that let's talk about
the man who did go out hunting for
someone that night and this map is a lot
and no one is discounting this I am a
black man in America I am full I've been
a target I've been assaulted so it's one
of those things that I will never ever
have any kind of patience for that but
also this is the deal - there's a
forgiveness and accountability go hand
in hand it's crazy you cannot have
accountability without forgiveness or
forgiveness without accountability
because you have to move on you have to
continue to live your life that's what I
understand the guy that assaulted me I
forgave it so that I can move on this is
this movement needs it needs leaders it
does not need martyrs
[Music]